[Musique]
bonjour théo je m'appelle karine je suis
éducatrice spécialisée
comme tu le sais ta maman on peut pas
s'occuper de toi dans l'immédiat mais
elle nous a chargés de veiller sur toi
et nous on est là pour ça pour toi on
t'accueille comme tu es si ta maman
maintient son choix des personnes vont
prendre une décision pour toi et tu
auras un papa et une maman d'adoption
pour la vie si elle se rétracte
alors on l'accueillera et on l'aidera à
se retrouver et à s'occuper de toi
en attendant cette décision tu vas aller
faire une étape chez jean il va prendre
soin de toi
je peux bien sûr couple
vous chantez ans
je dis
s'allumant matin au caire
m
moi ça m'a pris un peu de temps avant de
pouvoir l'envisager
enfin d'accepter que je n'aurai jamais
d'enfants moi c'est peut-être pas la
peine de le mettre dans votre rapport
un bon candidat l'adoption c'est pas
quelqu'un carrés avec une ouvreuse dans
la vie on a tous ses champs de mines et
des champs de fleurs
nous ce qu'on veut savoir c'est si vous
avez réussi à déminer votre champ
[Musique]
c'est un petit gars voulaient le voir
bonjour je suis assistante sociale je
veux pas le garder
je vous appelle parce qu'on va sûrement
avoir un petit peu pied accueillir
probablement demande vous seriez dispo
m'a proposé de faire un accueil j'arrive
que j arrete calage fait un jour bonjour
théo je m'appelle karine tu éducatrices
spécialisées comme tu le sais ta maman
on peut pas s'occuper de toi dans
l'immédiat mais elle nous a chargés de
veiller sur toi et nous on est là pour
ça pour toi pour continuer à bien moins
artus est un bon point du poids
le conseil de famille a donné ses
directives pour trouver des parents ce
petit et où ali flanc droit
sa première demande d'agrément daddy à 8
ans elle est prête cette femme c'est bon
moment pour être je le sais je me sens
carrément prête
[Musique]
tu grimpes tu grimpes du groupe
mon travail c'est pas trouvé un enfant
des parents qui sont
mon travail c'est de trouver les
meilleurs parents possible des enfants
en difficulté
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
tu est un super mec
[Musique]